>> Speaker One: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Ann Brener: Good afternoon.
On behalf of Mary-Jane
Deeb, Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
I would like to welcome you
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Ann Brener
and I'm a specialist
in the Hebraic Section, here.
In the spring of 2017 the
Library of Congress learned
of an extraordinary
treasure on the market,
a most unique ancient fragment
from the biblical
book of Exodus.
Just how unique you'll
soon be hearing
from our wonderful speaker.
Now, the story of Exodus is one
of the foundational
texts of Western culture.
It is woven into the American
narrative about freedom
and it resonates powerfully
in American history.
What could be more
fitting, therefore,
than to bring this ancient
treasure to the Library
of Congress, the national
library of the nation founded
on the principle of freedom?
Now, the ancient
treasure is actually here.
And for this, we have to
thank the people at the helm
of the library, the ones who
make the actual decisions
on what to apply and what not.
It takes more, I think, than
the power of the purse to make
to make that kind of decision.
To quote from the Hebrew poem
written by a grateful poet
to this patron over thousand
years ago in medieval Spain,
''It also takes heart
and mind and eye.''
And those words remain
true, today.
Please, join me, therefore,
in making Mary-Jane Deeb,
the Chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division,
Beacher Wiggins,
Director of Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access.
And most of all, I
think, Helena Zinkham,
Director of Collections
and Services.
Without them we wouldn't be
celebrating here to today.
Today's speaker also played
an important role behind
the scenes.
It was to him I turned
when I first learned
of this ancient scroll sheet
and it was his expertise
that guided me during
the crucial first stage.
For this reason, I am
delighted, doubly delighted,
that the day has finally come
when we can welcome Professor
Rendsburg into our meeting room
and hear more about
our new treasure.
In addition to being my
own special consultant Gary
Rosenburg, Rendsburg is
a distinguished professor
of Jewish history at
Rutgers University,
where he holds the Blanche
and Irving Laurie Chair
in Jewish History.
He is author of seven books of
Biblical literature and language
and about 170 articles.
That's one seven zero.
Perhaps, his best-known
book is the Bible
and Ancient Near
East co-authored
with the late Sirus Gordon.
He has also produced two DVDs
for The Great Courses program,
one on the book of Genesis and
one on the Dead Sea Scrolls.
He is, also, my former professor
from graduate school in Cornell
and I'm sure is grading
me today.
So, please join me in welcoming
Professor Gary Rendsburg.
[ Applause ]
>> Gary Rendsburg: Thank
you, very much, Ann,
for those very kind words and
it's such a pleasure to be here.
And as you said, you
use the word celebrate.
It's truly a time of celebration
to reflect on the arrival
of the remarkable 1,000-year-old
Torah scroll sheet now here
at the Library of Congress.
The oldest Torah scroll
sheet in the world,
complete Torah scroll
legible to the naked eye.
And that's how we can define
this treasure that is now part
of the Library of Congress.
So, let's discuss
how it got here,
why it's so important,
why it's so unique.
And just join me for this
amazing beautiful ride.
So, as Ann said, in
last spring in May 2017,
she sends me an email
and she says,
''Would you please take
a look at this catalog?''
And these are some
snippets from this catalog,
''The 19th Century Rare
Book and Photograph Shop''.
And they have offices in
both Brooklyn, New York
and Stevenson just outside
of Baltimore, Maryland.
''And please, go look at
this item, in particular,
on page 129 of the
catalog.'' Which I do.
And I read it and it
says, as you can see here,
that is all we have to go on.
Exodus 1010 through 1615.
Complete biblical
scroll sheet in Hebrew.
A Torah scroll panel, Middle
East, tenth or 11th century.
And then, a more
detailed description.
So, when I see this, and I'll
just close, give you a close-up
on the most important part
of the catalog description.
I know, immediately, what it is.
And that's because those
of us who work in the field
of Hebrew manuscripts keep
track of these things.
We certainly know where they
are in public collections,
in libraries, and
museums around the world.
And even, those which
are in private hands,
we learn about from
time to time.
This one was sold at
Christie's in London in 2001,
and therefore, I knew about it.
But, of course, one never
knows who the seller is
or who the buyer is
in such private sales
through auction houses like
Christie's or Sotheby's
and other such institutions
in the world.
Now, that I know
exactly what it was.
I had a pretty good
hint, but of course,
I didn't remember Exodus
1010 through Exodus 1615.
I said that must be it, but I
of course went back
and double checked.
And indeed, it was.
Why did I know about it?
Because, kudos to Jordan
Penkower, my colleague
at Bar Ilan University
in Israel.
Who, in the year 2002 was able
to publish a very
long detailed article
about the Torah scroll
sheet that is now here
at the Library of Congress.
Which, is to say when it was
for auction in London in 2001,
he as an expert in
medieval Hebrew manuscripts
and Torah scrolls, in
particular, was invited to come
to London to study it.
So, that it would, at
least, be available
for the scholarly world.
Even though, it would,
presumably, be purchased
by somebody in private
hands as it was.
And here is his description
of it, exactly,
with the same verse, of
course, that are in the catalog
that we just looked at.
And the same dimensions
and so on.
So, I confirmed by looking
at Jordan Penkower's article
from 16, at that
time, 15 years ago,
that this was, indeed,
the sheet.
And I emailed Ann back.
I think her email to me was
something like, ''Is this real?
Is this possible?
It's too good to be true.''
Is was something like that.
And I wrote her and I said.
''This is real.
Buy it if you can.'' Right.
Obviously, okay.
And Ann already described
the processes, of course,
at any institution, as
we are all aware of,
of how such a thing
needs to be obtained.
Pardon? Right.
So, it was purchased by the
library, as we've just heard.
Now, Penkower published, when
he published his very long,
detailed article, two very
not so good photos from,
I don't know if he took
them with his own camera.
Black and white photos
from 2001, 2002.
And these are the two photos
he took, and a portion
of column three and a
portion of column five,
just to give us a sense.
Now, column five is
the important one
because as you see there,
while the entire text,
and I'll show it to you,
again, in a few moments,
is written out in prose.
The portion of Exodus 15
known as the Song of the Sea,
Shirat Ha Yam in Hebrew,
is written out in poetry.
And it's a very well-known
poetic structure
that biblical text
of Torah scrolls
of this particular song
use the poetic style.
So, there you see some of
the handwriting up close
and personal in images which
are taken some years ago.
I also went online and there
is an auction record of it
from this invaluable.com,
which you know,
tracks and keeps records
of all these things.
And again, a very poor
image on the left,
upper left there you can see
of the of scroll fragment.
And on the right, a
bilingual inscription.
I'll show you a better
copy in a moment.
In Russian and in Hebrew,
which gives us a clue as to
where it was, at least
in the year 1863.
And that inscription is
on the back of the scroll.
We learned from this
that it was presented
by a man named Shelomo Beim.
He was the Karaite Hazzan in
the Crimea in the 19th century.
We know about him from
other sources, as well.
So, the Karaites
are a group of Jews
who do not follow the
rabbinic approach.
The rabbinical movement
which arose in the second
and third century CE has
been the dominant one
down to the present day.
And all modern streams of
Judaism, orthodox, conservative,
reform, Reconstructionist,
and now in the 21st century
renewal, and everything else.
Are all based on the
rabbinic system as laid
out by the classical rabbis in
the Mishnah and the Talmidim.
The Karaites have a totally
different approach to Judaism
which does not use the rabbinic
system and they are a community
of about 50,000 down
to the present day.
Mainly in Israel,
but once upon a time,
spread out throughout
the near East.
Large communities in Egypt and
in parts of Russia, as well,
both in Lithuania and next door.
So, this is Shelomo
Beim, a Karaite Hazzan,
leader of the community.
I think Hazzan in the Karaite
system means less the canter
in the synagogue, but rather,
the one who oversees
the community.
And he gave it as a gift to
the Grand Duke Constantine,
the brother of Czar
Alexander II in the year 1863.
That's what the Russian and
Hebrew inscription says.
And again, I'll show you
a better image of it.
We now have a very
good image of it.
So, it tells us, of course,
that this was there in 1863.
How did it get there?
According to Penkower and
everybody else who's seen it,
it is written in
the Middle East.
That is to say, we can tell
handwritings and we divide them
up into various geographical
zones.
Spain, which we call
the Sephardic one.
Europe which we call northern
Europe, the Ashkenazi one.
The Yemenite one.
And this would be the
Middle Eastern hand.
And it's pretty clear that
it came from the Middle East.
And based on other
elements, we know that it's
about 1,000 years old.
So, when I was here in the
October 2017, it was still,
it had recently arrived
and it was still
in its original glass
case and frame.
So, you get a sense of
what it looked like.
And notice all the folds.
Right. So, how do we retrace
the story of this scroll?
Now, here you see it today
after it's been stabilized,
not yet fully conserved,
but at least stabilized.
And I want to draw
attention to Yasmeen Khan,
who is sitting here
in the front row.
Conservator here at the library,
who will be doing further work
on the conservation
of this scroll
in the weeks and months ahead.
And here you have
the before and after.
Now, I wrote before
and after conservation
because I thought this
was already conserved,
since it looked so good to
my eye in the photograph.
But there Yasmeen
tells me no, it hasn't,
actually, been conserved, yet.
This is the stabilization.
And at least, to get it onto
display, since it was on display
in the Great Hall, here at the
library back in March and April.
So, it looks like
to me, to my eye,
that this has already been
put on the ironing board,
don't try this at
home, and smoothed out.
But apparently, there is still
much more work to be done.
So, what are all
the folds about?
Right. I mean, would,
we have no knowledge.
We don't know how it
got from Russia in 1863,
where it was, to London in 2001.
But, I'll come back
and give you, at least,
some speculation about that.
Here's the note.
You can see it much better now.
Mainly in Russian,
but, also, some Hebrew
and giving us the details,
which I described a moment ago.
On the back of the, of
the back of the scroll.
It's on the back of
the scroll, correct.
Yeah, okay.
Now, let me introduce you
to one of the great figures
of Jewish history,
Abraham Firkovich.
He was a hakham, a
wise man, literally.
Meaning a leader of
the Karaite community.
And those are the
years of his life.
You can see that he lived
to be almost 100 years, no,
to be almost 90 years old.
And he is famous because
throughout the 19th century,
he left Russia where he
was from, Karaite community
that I just described.
And he traveled throughout
the near East,
and he brought back
manuscripts by huge numbers.
Treasures of things that
had never been seen before
by European scholars,
as he traveled throughout
the Middle East in the land
of Israel and in
Syria and in Egypt.
And wherever he went in what
was then the Ottoman Empire.
And he brought back
these great treasures.
The most famous treasure he
brought back is the so-called
Leningrad Codex, the
oldest complete copy
of the Bible that we possess.
With a colophon, a inscription
that, giving us information
about the scribe and the year.
Written in the year 1009 CE in
Tiberias in the land of Israel.
And he brought that
back to Russia
and it is now in St. Petersburg.
When it was published
during the 1920s, the city,
of course, was called Leningrad.
So, people call it
the Leningrad Codex.
I think we should start
calling it St. Petersburg Codex
because the city has
reverted to that name.
And of course, I do think
there's some irony in the fact
that years from now, centuries
from now, or millennium
from now, everybody
will have forgotten
who Vladimir Lenin was.
And his name will live
on only in the name
of the Leningrad Codex.
How's that for an irony?
Of course, my students have
already forgotten who Lenin was.
They think maybe was
one of the Beatles,
but they don't even know
anything about that.
Okay. So, Firkovich brings
the Leningrad Codex back
and it is deposited
in the Imperial,
what was then the Imperial
Library in St. Petersburg,
where resides to
the present day.
And presumably, he is the one
who must have brought the scroll
that we have here at the Library
of Congress, scroll sheet back.
We don't know that for sure,
but his fingerprints,
quotation mark.
Right. His fingerprints are all
over such a document that came
from the Middle East
to Russia by a Karaite,
into the Karaite community.
And then, given to the royal
family, as I indicated.
And then, presumably, somebody
got it out of the Russia,
folded it up, smuggled it out.
We don't know, and just
winds up, hence, the fold.
And it just winds up
in London and it's
on the auction market
in the year 2001.
That's as much as we can say
about this, about the history
of this, of this document.
Now, as I mentioned before.
Oh, and it was on
display, as I said,
right next to the Gutenberg
Bible in the Great Hall.
And so, I've tried to
recreate a little bit of that
for you right here, with
the image of the Great Hall,
of the scroll sheet, and the
Library's Gutenberg Bible.
So, and I know it was visited
by many people while was
on display, just not too far
from where we are
seated, right now.
And therefore, we can
say based on, although,
I will demonstrate this in the
second part of my talk, still.
That this is, to repeat,
the oldest complete Torah scroll
sheet legible by the naked eye.
As we'll see in the second half,
there are other Torah scroll
sheets that are incomplete,
that are torn, that we can read.
Or maybe they are complete
but we can't read them,
they are so black.
So, this gains the title
of the oldest complete
Torah scroll sheet legible
by the naked eye.
Now, you can't see it on these
images, but on the far left
and on the far right are
the remains of thread.
So, remember that a Torah scroll
sheet, this is five columns,
is written on a single
sheet of parchment.
And then, they are sewn together
to create the large scroll
with a large rolled text.
So, this would have been
a single sheet connected
to Genesis and the beginning
of Exodus on the one end.
The rest of Exodus and
all of Leviticus, Numbers,
and Deuteronomy, the five books
of the Torah on the other end.
What happened to the rest?
Why was the single
sheet preserved?
Right. These are the
things we simply don't know.
But I think because of the
special nature of Exodus 15,
which we'll talk about
just a moment the poem
that you see here, that this
would have been the most
treasured part of the
of the Torah text.
Now, here is Exodus
15, as we just said.
And with that, we have an
interlude and I'm going
to invite Joseph Englesberg
up here to join me,
because we're going
to do a little bit
of a dramatic presentation
for you.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So, for those of you who do
not know the text of Exodus 15,
we'll give you just a
little bit of it in English
and just a few lines in Hebrew.
And so, this is the story of the
crossing of the Sea of Reeds,
where the Israelites have left
Egypt in Exodus chapter 12.
And a few chapters
later, chapters 14 and 15,
Pharaoh's had a change of
heart and he sends the army
out to track down the
Israelites in the wilderness.
And they are trapped with
the Egyptian army behind them
and the sea in front of them.
And you all know the story.
The sea split and the Israelites
passed through and the Egyptians
in pursuit, the sea
comes back together
and drowns the Egyptians.
Safely on the other
side of the sea,
the Israelites sing this text.
And it is, according to those
of us who work on the history
of the Hebrew language and
Biblical texts and dating them,
it is, probably, the
oldest Hebrew composition
that we possess.
Exodus Chapter 15,
the Song of the Sea.
And it goes like this.
>> Joseph Englesberg:
I will sing to the Lord
for He has triumphed
gloriously; the horse
and its rider he has
thrown into the sea.
>> Gary Rendsburg: The Lord
is my strength and my song
and he has become my salvation.
This is my God, and
I will praise Him;
the God of my father
and I will exalt Him.
>> Joseph Englesberg:
The Lord is a man
of war; the Lord is his name.
>> Gary Rendsburg: Pharaoh's
chariots and his host he cast
into the sea and his
choice officers are sunk
in the Sea of Reeds.
>> Joseph Englesberg:
The floods cover them.
They went down to the
depths like a stone.
>> Gary Rendsburg: Your
right hand, oh Lord,
glorious in power;
your right hand,
oh Lord, shatters the enemy.
>> Joseph Englesberg:
In the greatness
of your majesty you
overthrow your adversaries.
You sent forth your fury; it
consumes them like stubble.
>> Gary Rendsburg: At the blast
of your nostrils the waters
piled up, the flood stood
up in a heap, the
deeps congealed
in the heart of the sea.
>> Joseph Englesberg: The
enemy said, I will pursue.
>> Gary Rendsburg:
I will overtake.
>> Joseph Englesberg: I
will divide the spoil.
>> Gary Rendsburg: My desire
shall have its fill of them.
>> Joseph Englesberg:
I will draw my sword.
>> Gary Rendsburg: My
hand shall destroy them.
>> Joseph Englesberg: You blew
with your wind, he
sea covered them.
; they sank as lead
in the might waters.
[ Foreign Language
Spoken By Gary Rendsburg ]
>> Joseph Englesberg:
Who is like you,
oh Lord, among the gods?
majestic in holiness,
awesome in glorious
deeds, doing wonders?
>> Gary Rendsburg: And then
we're skipping the second half
of the poem.
We've read the first half of it.
Until we get to the final line.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Joseph Englesberg: The Lord
shall reign forever and ever.
>> Gary Rendsburg: And at this
point the text returns to prose.
The last two lines of the text
that you see here, on the image,
return to the block prose.
And we get these little,
you know, few more verses
about what's happening.
And then, in a remarkable stroke
of early iron age
egalitarianism,
the Hebrew text is
voiced through the women
who were with the Israelites.
And with that, we ask Rachel
Becker, of the Library staff,
the Hebraic Division, to join
us to play the female role
because the text
then says in prose,
then Miriam, Miriam, not Miriam.
Dressed appropriately.
Then, Miriam the Prophetess, the
sister of Aaron, took a timbrel
in her hand and all of the
women went out after her
with timbrels and dancing.
And Miriam sang to them.
>> Rachel Becker:
Sing to the Lord,
for He has triumphed gloriously!
The horse and its rider he
has thrown into the sea!
>> Gary Rendsburg:
Isn't that beautiful?
[ Applause ]
Thank you, Joseph.
Thank you, I almost
called you Miriam.
Thank you, Rachel.
You're so good.
Now. Okay.
Well, we'll do it from here.
I just wanted to point
out a few features
of this scroll beyond
the poetry.
Those of you who know Torah
scrolls, this predates some
of the features of
the Torah scroll
that you would be familiar with.
First of all, there is
no left justification.
Let's remember that Hebrew is
written from right to left.
So, the columns begin
right justified.
But there is no attempt to
do any left justification.
Some lines are slightly shorter.
Some lines are slightly longer.
Can everybody see that, right?
Today in the Middle Ages, the,
the tradition of doing right
and left justification
developed.
And so, this predates that.
How did scribes the Middle Ages
do right and left justification?
What if the long, what
if the word was just
too long or too short?
What they do?
Right. They created what
we call dilated letters.
They would take certain Hebrew
letters like the final Mem
and stretch it out a little bit.
Right. So, they would make,
they would get that right
and left justification.
You don't see that here.
Seven letters of
the Hebrew alphabet
in Torah scrolls have
little crowns on them.
Little tittles on tops of
the letters, which we call
in Hebrew, ''Tagin'',
meaning crowns.
And these, this scroll
has none of that.
Right. This doesn't, this
doesn't, this is not part
of this tradition, yet.
The last and the third feature,
which you do, which you see
on medieval and contemporary
scrolls but you don't see here.
There is a tradition to begin
each column with the letter Vav.
The commonest letter in the
Hebrew alphabet is the word Vav,
the letter Vav, which
means the word and.
And it is so ubiquitous that
you could actually space
out a Torah scroll and have
every single column begin
with that letter Vav.
What is known in the Hebrew
tradition is [foreign language],
the Vavs of the columns.
That is not present
here, either.
So, no left justification,
no tagin, the little tittles,
and no attempt to lay out the
text so that the letter Vav is
at the beginning of each column.
That is not to be
found here, at all.
And of course, that
helps us understand
that this is a very
ancient scroll,
unlike all other,
all other scrolls.
Also, and it's almost
impossible to see on this image,
there are occasional
corrections.
Now, according to Jewish law
and, certainly, as practiced
by later scribes from, let's
say, the 13th century onward,
if you make a mistake you have
to scrape it off
or just restart.
Or just, you know, can't use it
for liturgical purposes
in the synagogue.
This apparently either
ignores that or it's too early
to be participating in that
legal tradition or custom.
And therefore, you do see
occasional corrections here.
Some of them by, one of them
in particular, adds a word.
I don't think you can
see it, but right up here
between the lines, I mean,
I can't see it myself,
either, at the moment.
There is a, the Hebrew word
Et, which doesn't have, really,
any meaning, but
note, it informs you
that the direct object
is to follow,
is inserted between
the two lines.
Because the scribe had
left it out and went back
and made that correction.
And there's occasional
other corrections.
One in particular, down here
and be, towards the bottom
of the third column, where they
change the paragraphing system.
You can see white spaces which
are indicating paragraphs.
So, that was changed, as well.
I do, I should point out that
the only place you see the left
justification is in
the five prose lines
in the upper left
before the song,
and the five immediate
lines below the song.
Right. Before the, above
and below the poem.
There, you can actually see the
left justification, as well.
Okay. Now, how do we know
that this is really the oldest
complete Torah scroll sheet
legible to the naked eye?
Let's take a tour of that
in the second half
of this presentation.
So, the Ein Gedi Synagogue on
the shore of the Dead Sea dates
to the fifth to the
seventh century.
It was excavated in the 1970s.
Here is a photo of the
way it looks, today.
It's outdoors.
You just see the foundation.
How many of you have
been to Ein Gedi?
Anybody? Worth a stop at
this beautiful synagogue
with a mosaic floor.
There's a tent over
it now, to protect it.
And this is the area, this is
the area of the Torah scroll arc
where the, would have been
a wooden box of some sort
where the Torah scrolls
would have been kept.
The Torah scroll
niche, the Torah niche.
And in the excavations in
1970 this was found there.
A burnt scroll.
And it is charred,
it is impossible,
must been an accidental fire.
It is impossible to open up.
The archaeologists just kept it.
Right. They just kept it
for 45 years thinking one
day technology will catch up.
And it did, because we
now can do CT scanning,
which you probably think was
invented for medical purposes
but was really invented
to read old Torah scrolls.
And here it is with the
Bruker Skyscan model 1176.
Right. We have the 1076 at home.
That's why we couldn't do
it ourselves, but we figured
out how to do it with somebody.
And they did the scroll.
And here is, of course, it would
be black ink on white parchment,
but you all know because
x-rays know these other kinds
of MRIs and CT scans.
It's always inverted imaging.
And so, here is the
white letters.
And turns out to be the
beginning of the book Leviticus.
This was done in 2015.
Next year, the scientists
went deeper into the scroll
and this is still not been,
this is digitally unrolled.
Do you realize what we're
talking about, here?
Right. Digitally unwrapped,
digitally unrolled.
And here is now the
complete scan
of the scroll beginning
Exodus chapters one and two.
You'll notice that there
is a blank sheet right
in front of it, here.
Okay. That tells us that this
scroll was not a complete scroll
of Torah, but only the
book of Leviticus, right.
Because, otherwise,
you'd see the end
of Exodus before the
beginning of Leviticus.
That it was just
Leviticus or, maybe,
the second half of the Torah.
Maybe, they used Genesis
and Exodus in one scroll,
and then Leviticus, Numbers,
Deuteronomy in another.
But this tells us this is
the beginning of the scroll
and it starts with Leviticus.
By the way, what do we call that
blank sheet at the beginning?
A protocol.
Protocol in Greek means
''that which was glued
to the beginning of a scroll''.
And in the Greek manuscripts or,
even in other later manuscripts,
they would give you notations
as to what's in the scroll.
So, you would just
have to open up.
That was the protocol.
Okay. The Jews didn't do that.
They just put a blank sheet
there and didn't write on it
because you just opened up
and saw it was Leviticus.
And yes, there's a Lincoln penny
there because the scientists
who did the work were at
the University of Kentucky.
And so, this is there homage to
their most famous native son.
At the Weitzman Institute
in Israel, it was subjected
with a small piece
to a carbon-14 test
and dated to around 300 CE.
And since the synagogue is from
the sixth or seventh centuries,
this informs us that
a scroll was in use
for several centuries.
Three-four centuries
inside the synagogue
for liturgical purposes.
And here it is, digitally
unwrapped now,
with the black on white.
Why we can play with the images.
Thank you, scholars
and scientists,
who help us out with
all of this work.
This one is, actually,
in the US.
This is known as
Ashkar-Gilson number two.
It's in the David M.
Rubenstein Rare Book
and Manuscript Library
at Duke University.
And I mentioned his name because
he has been a great benefactor
of book culture and is
a member of the Library
of Congress Board,
if I'm not mistaken.
So, he is a major player
in preserving books
and manuscripts from
centuries ago.
This is already digitally
enhanced.
You can almost read
nothing of this.
It so happens to,
also, be Exodus 15.
And you can see the scroll,
the layout of the poem
that we just read
and that we just saw
on our scroll sheet,
you can see it here.
But A, it's not complete, and B,
it's almost impossible
to read anything.
I've been to the Duke library.
I've seen this with my own eyes
and, trust me, there's not much
that one can actually
read by looking at it,
unless you have some digital
enhancement as you see here.
Here it is much more legible
with some more photo
enhancement.
Dated to around 700 CE.
And there's an up
close, really beautiful.
There is this scroll,
which was in London.
How I got to London,
we don't know.
It was in London for up until
the 20th century, and maybe even
into the 21st century,
at Jews' College,
a training ground
for rabbis in the UK.
And it's a complete sheet,
as you can see here,
of seven columns.
And it includes a large chunk
of the book of Exodus leading
up to the material that we
just saw on the previous one.
Now, this, also, cannot be
read with the naked eye.
And it's now, also, in the
private hands of a collector.
It has recently been
determined that these, actually,
come from the same sheet.
In other words, the paleography
experts who worked on this,
the handwriting experts,
which we call paleographers.
Now, tell us that the
London scroll on the right,
which is now in private hands,
and the Ashkar-Gilson
scroll fragment at Duke,
come from the same scroll with
a column in between missing.
And this was recently
worked out by Edna Engel
and Mordechay Mishor
in Jerusalem.
Ashkar-Gilson collection
has another scroll fragment.
Nobody can read anything
on this.
But, welcome to photography.
Via multispectral imaging
we can read everything, now.
And for those you who can
read Hebrew, this is a version
of the Ten Commandments in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter 5.
Isn't it great to live
in the 21st century
where we can do all this?
Here are some scroll sheets
that are, also, very old
and are legible to
the naked eye.
They all come from
the Cairo Genizah,
Cambridge University
Library collection.
TS stands for Taylor-Schechter.
This one is dated to around 800
CE by the paleography experts.
It's from Genesis, but
again, not complete.
How do we know it's a Torah
scroll and not something else?
Because the back is blank.
Right. Eventually, the Jews
will move from the Torah scroll
to the Codex, which is the
forerunner of the modern book,
where you will have
writing on both sides.
But all the things I'm talking
about here are scrolls
and scroll sheets.
Jews will continue to
use the scroll format
down to the present
day in the synagogue
for liturgical purposes of
the reading of the Torah
and the book of Esther.
But we can take images.
We have images of these things
to show us both the
recto and the verso.
Here is a close-up of
just one small passage
from Genesis chapter 14.
And I've given you
the Hebrew text
in its later Masoretic
apparatus,
so you can comparison there.
This comes from the
same scroll, as well,
as the paleographers
now tell us.
Also, in Cambridge, but the
earlier parts of Genesis.
A small fragment from
around a century later.
There it is blank.
From a century later, we
have another fragment.
See the seam?
So, you can see how these
would have been two sheets
that were sewn together.
These are all in
Cambridge, originally found
in the Cairo synagogue, the
Cairo Genizah collection.
Blank on the reverse.
One of the best examples of
what can happen in the history
of manuscripts is this.
Does everybody see what this is?
Well, you can't come to a
Library of Congress talk
in this division and not
hear the word palimpsest.
This is a palimpsest.
Right. It is an old
Hebrew manuscript
where the ink was scraped off,
and then a later scribe
wrote Greek on top of it.
That, we call palimpsest,
where things were scraped off.
This is from the used
parchment market.
And we have so many palimpsests
from the early Middle Ages
because it was hard
to get parchment.
It was a lot of work
And so, you would have
to constantly rework it
and scrape it and if
you did need it anymore.
We don't know how this Hebrew
text was no longer being used.
But it's a Torah scroll
underneath that was, somehow,
got into Christian hands and a
Greek writing scribe wrote this.
This is in the Medici
Library in Florence.
And actually, we now know
from further analysis
that six different handwritings
are on the under text.
And it dates from more or less
the same time as the new Library
of Congress Torah scroll sheet.
And here we are, again.
And so, with that
little review we can say,
as I said a moment
ago, that the Library
of Congress Torah scroll
sheet is the oldest sheet
in the world legible
to the naked eye.
Right. Do we have
all the material?
Yes. Can we read them?
Either, they are fragmentary,
so they're not complete.
Or we can't read them
and we only need photo
enhancement to read them.
So, here you have it to repeat
the oldest Torah scroll sheet
legible to the naked eye, dated
to around 1,000 years ago.
To conclude, if you're
interested
where our oldest Torah scrolls
complete are to be found.
And I've shown you very
fragmentary material.
The oldest complete Torah
scroll in the world is
in the University Library
in Bologna, recently dated
with carbon-14 testing
to the year 1190 CE.
And if you go back, in
this case, about 800 years,
the plus minus of carbon-14
dating is really only
about a 50-year window.
So, it dates from 1140 to
1240, or something like that.
In the C-14 test, we
split the difference
and we come out with 1190.
And you can see the image
has been opened up again
to the same text that
we've been looking at,
the poem of Exodus 15.
Next time in your
Bologna, go to the library
and request to see
this treasure.
That's the oldest complete
Torah scroll we have.
What about the oldest complete
Torah scroll still in use?
Not in a university library,
still in a synagogue?
At the northern Italian
city of Biella,
where there is a small Jewish
community not far from Milan,
this Torah scroll
is still in use.
It's in the synagogue.
And it, also, was recently
dated by carbon-14.
You need just a little fleck.
So, they took a little
fleck of the parchment.
In the old days you'd
need huge amount,
but today you can just take
like a fingernail worth.
And both of these tests
were conducted, by the way,
at the University of Illinois,
which has the best C-14 lab
in the U.S. And why they send it
to the U.S. instead of someplace
in Europe, I don't know.
But they were both done here.
And this one is from 1250 CE.
Again, a plus minus of a
bit in either direction.
But it gives you a sense of
how old these manuscripts are,
how old and how well preserved
the ink on the parchment can be.
Because these were done with
the best quality materials.
Right. These were sacred
texts, which the scribes
and the communities who
used them knew would last
for centuries.
And they took the best
parchment and the best ink
and had the best scribal hands.
And together, produced
these magnificent documents,
including the one that is now
here at the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Questions.
>> Ann Brener: Thank
you, Professor Rendsburg,
for an absolutely
wonderful lecture.
If I can turn the
tables on my professor,
I'd give him an A plus.
We have a display of rare booked
for you and an opportunity
to see this incredible
scroll sheet in the back.
And we have a surprise
for you, also.
We have Senior Conservator,
Yasmeen Khan, who is going
to speak in front of the
scroll sheet and tell us
about all the conservation
work they're going to be doing.
But first, we have time
for a few questions.
So, I'll return the microphone
to Professor Rendsburg.
>> Gary Rendsburg: Thanks.
Questions.
Yes, sir.
>> Speaker One: This sheet
is, obviously, now a fragment,
but it is missing a corner.
I was wondering what the
criteria [inaudible].
>> Gary Rendsburg: I would
put an asterisk there
and say it's missing a few words
in the upper right-hand corner.
Yeah, right.
To me, this is complete.
This is as close as we're
going to get to, to complete.
So, you know, it's
a technicality.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I'm sorry, I didn't
hear your question.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should have said this,
I should have said this.
Thank you, for reminding me.
The question is, ''Are there any
scrolls from the BCE period?''
And I neglected to mention,
it's very important.
Thank you.
The Dead Sea Scrolls
are our oldest,
amongst the Dead Sea Scrolls are
our oldest biblical documents.
Right. So, the Dead Sea Scrolls
date from the third, second,
and first centuries BCE.
Found in the 1940s and
1950s in the caves of Qumran
on the shore of the Dead Sea.
And there are 800
plus documents,
and 200 plus documents
are biblical manuscripts.
Okay. So, yes, we do.
Including Genesis,
Exodus, all of them.
Only one complete scroll and
that's the book of Isaiah.
All the others are fragmentary.
In fact, very fragmentary.
But thank you, for
that reminder.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, there is one version
of Exodus 15 amongst
the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Thank you.
But it is not written
in the poetic style.
It is written in block as
if were just prose blocking.
It would have been
read as poetry.
Right. The oral reading
tradition always would have read
it in a poetic fashion.
That would have been since
his time composition.
But it's earliest manifestation
in a graphic form in writing,
amongst the scrolls of the
Dead Sea Scrolls, it's not laid
out like you see here.
Okay. And by the way, I didn't
give you the Hebrew term.
I should give it to you, we.
The Jewish tradition has
always kept track of all
of these things with
different terms.
And in Hebrew, this is known
as a [foreign language].
Half brick over brick,
brick over half brick.
Everybody see the layout?
Right. This is the way of
brick, bricklaying goes.
Okay. You don't just
pile up bricks this way.
It's better to pile them
up half brick, brick,
half brick, brick, etcetera.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Okay. So, the question is about
the use of the Codex and the use
of the Masoretic material.
So, Masoretic is the
English word based
on the Hebrew word Masorah,
which means tradition.
There were a group of scholars
in the ninth, in the eighth,
ninth, and tenth centuries,
mainly in Tiberius, Israel,
but also, other places
including Babylonia.
Who created a graphic
representation of the vowels,
the punctuation, and so on.
For those of you don't know the
Hebrew system that we're looking
at here, there is nothing
here but the 22 letters
of the alphabet, which
are all consonants.
There are no vowels.
There are word breaks,
space between words.
But there's no punctuation.
It doesn't tell you
when a word ends.
So, this is the graphic
and it's the oldest,
the way to write the Hebrew
language in graphic form.
There was an oral reading
tradition, which I alluded
to a moment ago, where the
tradents, the oral readers,
knew how to intone a text.
They knew the vowels,
they knew the accents,
they knew the punctuation,
and so on.
Just like you know these
things from memory.
So, the Masoretes created a
graphic system to represent all
that in the eighth-ninth
century.
And at the same time, we have
the Jews adopting the Codex,
which was prior to that
associated with Christianity.
As I said, writing
on both sides.
So, all of that is
happening, you're correct,
in the eighth and
ninth centuries.
And the Leningrad Codex, which I
mentioned, is the tenth century.
The other famous one
is the Aleppo Codex
from the ninth century.
And, sorry, the tenth, Aleppo
Codex is tenth century.
The Leningrad Codex
is early 11th century.
But it doesn't have an
effect on Torah scroll.
Because for liturgical purposes,
religious tradition is the
most conservative aspect
of any society; Jewish,
Christian, Muslim,
Hindu, it doesn't matter.
And so, since the
Jews have been writing
out Torah scrolls going back
to the Dead Sea Scrolls,
to the Ein Gedi Synagogue scroll
that I showed you, and so on.
That was unaffected by
the shift to the Codex,
as it is down to
the present day.
Yes. Yeah.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Okay. The question is about
the kosher-ness of the scroll,
whether it's legally or
holotically [phonetic] fit
for the use in the synagogue.
And so, as I alluded to, we, our
working assumption is that all
of these scrolls were
for liturgical purposes.
Certainly, by this time, study
scrolls, reading scrolls were
in the form of the Codex,
which was a great leap
forward for book culture.
And the, had the
apparatus of vowels
and punctuation, and so on.
So, these only have been
used for liturgical purposes.
There can be no doubt
about that.
Okay. Yes.
Last one. Yeah.
One last question.
Go ahead.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Where can you learn
about Mister Firkovich,
the great Karaite collector?
Well, the biography of him
still needs to be written.
But there is a Wikipedia entry.
I mean, if you asked me where
to go I would say, of course,
go the start with
the Wikipedia entry.
Do know anybody who's written
on Firkovich beyond that?
I think that would be
the best place to go,
would start with Wikipedia.
There may be a few
references there.
The Encyclopedia Judaica.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah. The Encyclopedia
Judaica would have a entry.
And the old Jewish
Encyclopedia of 1906, probably,
has a good entry, as well.
And that's available
free and online.
Okay.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Someone has to.
Okay. A fascinating character
and I don't know how much
of his life we can put back
together at a distance of,
you know, a century
and a half, now.
But he, we all, we are
all in his great debt
for the work that he did.
But, yes. And so, he may have
a hand, he certainly has a hand
in all the material that's
in Saint Petersburg, today.
And he may even have had a
hand in this text, as well.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker One: This
has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.